vamos a ver algunos problemas
interesantes de división tenemos 280 y
lo dividimos entre 5 y los invito a que
pongan pausa en el vídeo y que traten de
aplicar la técnica que revisamos en el
vídeo pasado traten de descubrir el
resultado de dividir 280 entre 5 podemos
reescribir esto aquí abajo 280 dividido
entre 5 y la primera pregunta que nos
hacemos es cuántas veces cabe 5 en 2 y
vemos que en realidad el 5 no caben en
dos así que son 0 veces
0 por 50 y restamos 2 - 0 es igual a 2 y
bajamos el siguiente dígito que en este
caso es un 8 y ahora nos preguntamos
otra vez cuántas veces cabe en 5 en el
28 sin sobrepasar lo y podemos decir
bueno 5 por 5 es 25 5 por 6
30 es mayor que 28 así que regresamos a
5 por 5 entonces 5 cabe cinco veces en
28 5 por 5 es igual a 25 y restamos 28
menos 25 es igual a 3 y ahora bajamos el
siguiente dígito que en este caso es 0 y
preguntamos otra vez
cuántas veces cabe el 5 en el 30 y vemos
que en este caso cabe exactamente 6
veces 5 por 6 es 30 y restamos y no nos
queda ningún residuo acabamos de
descubrir que 280 dividido entre 5 es
igual a 56 es igual a 56 porque funciona
esto vamos a pensarlo bueno la primera
forma en que tratamos de resolverlo fue
pensando en 200 y queríamos poner algo
en la posición de las centenas y es como
decir cuántos cientos de veces cabe el 5
en el 200 y no hay múltiples en las
centenas para el 5 miren si se sienten
un poco confundidos no se preocupen lo
que quisiera es que pensaran un poco más
en el valor
y luego pasamos de 200 a 280 pasamos al
28 pero si vemos el 2 está en la
posición de las centenas y este 8 está
en la posición de las decenas este
veintiocho realmente está representando
doscientos ochenta y la pregunta es
cuántas decenas de veces cabe el 5 en
280 y vimos que cabe 5 decenas de veces
o lo que es lo mismo 50 veces 50 por 5
es igual a 250 y cuando restamos 280
menos 250 obtenemos 30 y como no hay
nada más en la posición de las unidades
entonces tenemos que descubrir cuántas
veces cabe 5 en 30 espero que esto les
ayude a entender lo que está pasando en
este proceso que tenemos aquí no es algo
mágico lo que realmente tenemos que
entender es el valor posicional y otra
cosa que les quiero enseñar es que no
necesariamente tenemos que escribir este
cero aquí hay otra manera de calcular
esto pudimos haber dicho doscientos
ochenta
dividido en 35
y preguntarnos cuántas veces cabe cinco
en dos y como sabemos que no cabe vamos
directamente al 28 y preguntamos cuántas
veces cabe 5 en 28 en este caso vamos a
pensar en 28 y sabemos que 5 por 5 es
igual a 25 y restamos restamos 28 menos
25 es igual a 3 y bajamos el 0 el 5 cabe
seis veces en treinta y cinco por seis
es igual a treinta y no nos queda ningún
residuo una vez más lo que realmente
estamos diciendo es que el 5 no cabe
cientos de veces en 200 si tuviéramos
500 podríamos decir bueno el 5 cabe 100
veces en 500 pero en lugar de eso
decimos cuántas veces cabe cinco en
doscientos ochenta y clave cincuenta
veces 50 por 5 es igual a 250 280 menos
250 es igual a 35 cabe seis veces en
treinta espero que esto les sirva